[Music]
hey buddy
[Music]
[Music]
or any morning good morning guys now
some of you asked me hey Daniel what do
you eat in a full day as a model so
that's what I'm gonna do in this video
let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
so the first thing that I do in the
morning is I drink a big glass of water
so I have a big glass of water well
there's a lot of reasons but the most
important reasons for me in the morning
is because it helps to flush those
toxins out and it also fires up the
metabolism so I drink around seven eight
nine glasses of water per day coffee in
the morning I gotta have my coffee even
before I have my breakfast because I
love good quality coffee without sugar
so I drink it let's say around one hour
after I've woken up and I use a French
press plunger now apart from texting
great coffee increases my brain function
metabolism and it also gives me energy
which I really need first thing in the
morning all right now let's fast-forward
to the breakfast
all right so for breakfast I love oats
oh so I use three tablespoons of oats
and then I add different kinds of fruit
and nuts good hey I worked out yesterday
so I'm also going to add whey protein
yes
but here's the thing if I need to lose a
bit of body fat percentage then I skip
breakfast to do intermittent fasting
where I only eat on 12 to 8 p.m. and for
the rest of the day
nothing so this is it just add a bit of
milk
all right there we go this is it
[Music]
now the thing is this is a huge
breakfast got a lot of calories so if I
want to have a breakfast with a little
bit less calories then I love to have a
good omelet with tomato cottage cheese
spinach and mushrooms
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Daniel get some water ha
thanks welcome [ __ ] tonight
yes cheaper dinner so ya gotta have less
water
right guys it's almost 8 o'clock and
it's time for it smooth so I'm gonna add
some milk and white protein from
MuscleTech nitro Tech why well because I
want to gain some more muscle mass and I
love this brand but you can also use
other good brands like optimum nutrition
alright and I'm gonna add a little bit
of peanut butter banana and also ice to
make it nice and cool
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
it's as amazing and not a good thing
about protein shakes is it a helps with
those sweet cravings
[Music]
not a glass of water so good
[Music]
alright guys I'm having my second cup of
coffee for today because I love coffee
if you're curious to what coffee I like
I'll add it for you in the video
description but I love to have coffee
especially while I work so I'm gonna
continue here to edit some videos for
you guys
[Music]
alright guys I'm still editing but it's
lunchtime I'm gonna quickly show you
what I ate for lunch time now you won't
believe this but my favorite lunchtime
meal is just basic eggs on toast but
okay it's not just basic accent you know
let me just show you what I mean so
first just holy toast bread then avocado
tomato jello Pinot's and two eggs now
the yellow should be runny and not hard
that's just what I like and then just to
finish it off smoothly
I add some African biltong on the side
it's like beef jerky but so much better
I will also add it for a new video
description if you want to check it out
now my lunch is not huge because I
already had a big breakfast with a lot
of calories and then also will finish
the lunch it with a glass of water
[Music]
all right guys it's around once between
2:00 and 3:00 p.m. and this is my third
coffee on my last coffee after Dane I
know some of you think Daniel I drink
too much coffee but it is fine as long
as you drink enough water in between now
I made a video for you where it
explained to you the health benefits of
coffee that you should definitely check
out after you're done with this video
oh and another tip if you use a French
press plunger let it just stay in there
for about two minutes before you pour it
in the longer it stays in there the
stronger that coffee is all right I got
to get back to editing but I'll see you
when I have my snack it's snack time and
right now we're having some mixed nuts
and some game biltong which is different
than the beef Bolton we had all right
guys very quick just to show you the
difference between normal beef biltong
which is this guy over here he's got a
lot more fat here and this is the
healthier option which is game meat and
you can see there's almost no fat in
this so this is what I'm having for a
snack and then also we have some water
again hmm right guys it's close to 6:00
yes so I'm gonna show you guys my
favorite dinner meal which is fish and
green vegetables so I'm thinking about
salmon because that's my favorite fish
though ha hey Daniel looks like I just
made it in time for dinner
right yeah you did I'm thinking about
some salmon and green veggies tuna
salmon man's I don't have a budget for
that I think a lot of people don't have
a budget for that so I brought some hey
what about some noble fish in chips it's
Friday night come on in ok if you want
to do it then the kitchen is all yours
but you got to make it healthy
I'll make it healthy I know how to make
it
[Music]
look at this egg let's do this I can do
it all strip Daniel by the way my name
is Louie nice to meet you guys
okay here's the chips no bad oils no fat
stuff nothing and it's gonna go into the
oven all right here we go
see guys so let me just explain to you
what's going on here
so we've got the awesome fish we got the
awesome pop I mean we got the chips
we've got the fish over here and now you
know that also you always speaks about
healthy vegetables healthy greens
vegetables so I'm adding some peace at
least it is sweet so I'm gonna enjoy it
as well so I don't think you'll be able
to say anything negative in this one
[Music]
yes Daniel huh my bad oh now this looks
good ready not back then it looks good
after watching your YouTube videos and I
learned a little bit of what is helping
was not mmm so is that waiting out of
the beast
it tastes good as well well done if you
guys are wondering where does Louie come
from Louie is my second name that's why
DL a mortal lifestyle is called D L M
because D is Daniel Louie and the M is
Moritz which is myself
welcome to deal in mortal lifestyle all
right guys I just had my workout is
right after 9 o'clock at night I know
it's a little bit late sometimes I have
to work out at night so just depends on
my schedule in the day sometimes I like
to work in the morning now it is the
best time to drink your protein shake
right after you had your workout because
these are broken down muscle tissues
neat protein to repair itself and it is
the best time to do it right after you
had your workout now I don't like to eat
a heavy meals at night to have a heavy
stomach so I'm just gonna use this with
plain water I'm not gonna make a
smoothie I'm not gonna add a lot of
different kind of fruits and stuff so
just water weight protein shake with
Wolverine over here alright
[Music]
there we go he's close to ten o'clock so
I'm gonna relax I just had a shower and
what I love to do is to drink
rooibos tea this is from South Africa it
has no caffeine in it it makes you calm
relaxed as you and it's so healthy for
yourself you're gonna quickly make this
[Music]
now this is my basic meal plan for
staying around 80 kilograms but I'm
planning a video where I go from skinny
to muscle and in that video I'll share a
lot more on nutrition I will also go a
bit more into the macros and why you
need to eat certain food so if you
haven't subscribed yet do it so you
won't miss any of the next videos cheers
guys
[Music]